maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa quantum na impormasyon at pagkalkula. Ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous at ako ang teknikal na direktor para sa edukasyon sa IBM Quantum
ito ang ika-13 na aralin ng serye at ito ang unang aralin sa ikaapat at huling yunit na tungkol sa quantum na pagkakamali
pagtutuwid. Ang Quantum Computing ay may potensyal na makapagbigay ng mahusay na solusyon sa mga gawaing pangkalkula na kung saan
ang mahusay na mga klasikal na algorithm ay hindi kilala at marahil ay hindi umiiral. Gayunpaman, may mga napaka-makabuluhang hamon na
kailangang malampasan kung nais nating ipatupad ang mga uri ng malawak na quantum na pagkalkula na umaasa tayong isang araw ay magiging
posible. Ang puso ng bagay ay ang quantum na impormasyon ay napaka-malutong. Literal mong masisira ito sa pamamagitan lamang ng
pagtingin dito. Kaya para gumana nang tama ang mga quantum computer ay kailangang ihiwalay ang quantum na impormasyon na
naka-imbak nila mula sa kapaligiran sa paligid nila sa sukdulan. Ngunit sa parehong oras ang quantum computer mismo ay kailangan ring magbigay sa atin ng
napaka-tumpak na kontrol sa quantum na impormasyong ito at kasama doon ang wastong pagsisimula, tumpak at maaasahang
mga unitary na operasyon at siyempre ang kakayahang magsagawa ng mga sukat upang makuha natin ang mga resulta ng
pagkalkula. Malinaw na may tensyon sa pagitan ng mga kinakailangang ito at sa mga unang araw ng quantum Computing mayroong ilang mga tao na naniwala na ang karupukan
ng quantum na impormasyon at ang pagkamaramdamin nito sa parehong mga kamalian at ingay mula sa kapaligiran ay magtatapos sa
pagpapaging imposible ng Quantum Computing. Ngayon ay halos walang duda na ang pagtatayo ng tumpak at maaasahang
malawak na quantum computer ay isang napakalaking hamon. Ngunit mayroon tayong isang pangunahing kasangkapan upang tulungan tayo sa pagsisikap na ito na nagpapaging optimistiko sa karamihan
ng mga taong may kaalaman sa larangang ito tungkol sa malawak na Quantum Computing na isang araw ay magiging katotohanan at ang kasangkapang iyon ay quantum na pagkakamali
pagtutuwid. Sa susunod na apat na aralin ay tatalakayin natin ang quantum na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali na may pokus sa
mga pangunahing kaalaman. Sa araling ito ay magkakaroon tayo ng unang sulyap sa quantum na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali kasama ang isa sa mga pinaka-unang quantum
na code sa pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali na natuklasan: ang 9 qubit Shore code. Tatalakayin din natin ang isa pang pangunahing konsepto sa Quantum
na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali na kilala bilang ang discretization ng mga pagkakamali. Sa mga susunod na aralin ng yunit ay makikita natin ang mas sopistikado at mas mabuting
mga konstruksyon ng quantum error correcting code at tatalakayin din natin ang problema ng quantum na pagkalkula sa naka-encode na quantum na impormasyon gamit ang
mga sangkap na pangkalkula na hindi rin perpekto at madaling magkamali. Narito ang isang maikling pangkalahatang-ideya ng
aralin. Magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagtalakay ng mga klasikal na repetition code na marahil ay ang pinakasimple at pinakabatayang uri
ng klasikal na error correcting code. Ang mga klasikal na repetition code ay hindi partikular na magagandang code ayon sa klasikal
na pamantayan ng teorya ng coding, lalo na sa kanilang sarili. Ngunit ayos lang iyon dito. Ang hanap natin dito ay pagiging simple at sa partikular
ay titingnan natin ang halos pinakasimpleng klasikal na error correcting code na maaari mong isipin na gagamitin natin bilang batayan para sa isang simpleng halimbawa
ng isang quantum error correcting code. Ang halimbawang iyon ay ang 9 qubit Shore code na tatalakayin natin nang detalyado
kasama ang paglalarawan ng code mismo pati na rin ang mga pamamaraan para sa pag-encode ng mga qubit gamit ang code na ito, pagtuklas ng mga pagkakamali sa mga naka-encode na qubit at
pagwawasto ng mga pagkakamaling iyon. At sa ikatlong bahagi ng aralin ay tatalakayin natin ang discretization ng mga Pagkakamali na nagpapahintulot sa atin na mag-isip tungkol sa mga arbitrary na pagkakamali sa
mga qubit na sa prinsipyo ay bumubuo ng isang patuloy na hanay ng mga posibilidad sa mga discrete na termino, na mahalagang binabalikan ang mga pagkakamali sa
mga tinatawag na bit flip at phase flip. Bago tayo pumunta sa mga teknikal na detalye ng quantum na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali ay
sulit na maglaan ng sandali upang isaalang-alang ang pangangailangan para sa quantum na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali pati na rin ang klasikal na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali
Tulad ng isinagad ko sa simula ng aralin ang mga quantum computer ay lubhang madaling kapitan ng mga pagkakamali dahil sa
karupukan ng quantum na impormasyon. Sa partikular, ang mga hindi gustong pakikipag-ugnayan sa kapaligiran o sa
madaling salita ang natitirang mundo ay maaaring guluhin ang quantum na impormasyon. Ang mga hindi gustong pakikipag-ugnayan na ito ay maaaring magdulot ng decoherence kung saan ang impormasyon
ay mahalagang tumatagos sa kapaligiran na nagdudulot ng impormasyong nakaimbak ng quantum computer na kumilos nang mas parang
klasikal. Napakahalaga rin na makilala natin na ang mga quantum na operasyon ay maaari lamang isagawa nang may limitadong
katumpakan. Halimbawa, maaaring gusto nating magsagawa ng isang partikular na quantum gate sa isang qubit ngunit dahil ang mga pisikal na device ay
hindi kailanman perpekto, ang talagang ipinapatupad natin ay maaaring isang approximation lamang sa gate na iyon. Maaaring hindi ito malaking problema para sa isang
gate lamang. Ngunit kung ang layunin natin ay magsagawa ng libu-libo o milyun-milyong quantum gate, ang mga maliliit na kamalian na ito ay
magsisimulang mag-ipon at kapag tapos na ang pagkalkula ay maaari tayong makarating sa napaka-ibang estado mula sa ating
inaasahan. Kaya ito ay isang medyo naiibang pinagmulan ng mga pagkakamali ngunit isa talaga ito na hindi natin maaaring
balewalain. Ang mga tao ay nag-aaral ng mga klasikal na error correcting code sa loob ng halos isang siglo at ang mga code na ito ay may maraming aplikasyon kasama ang
pagpapadala at pag-iimbak ng impormasyon. Ngunit dahil ang mga sangkap ng klasikal na pagkalkula ay napaka-mapagkakatiwalaan ay hindi natin talagang
kailangan ang pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali upang bumuo ng mga klasikal na computer. Ngayon maaaring ang pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali ay hindi talagang kailangan
upang bumuo ng maaasahang malawak na mga quantum computer. Halimbawa, ang pangunahing ideya sa likod ng topological Quantum
Computing ay na maaaring posible na bumuo ng matibay na quantum na sistema na inherente na protektado laban sa ingay dahil
sa mga topological na katangian ng mga sistema. Ngunit hindi natin alam kung ito ay magiging posible at medyo malawak na naniniwala
na ang pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali ay malamang na magiging mahalaga sa isang anyo o iba pa para sa malawak na Quantum Computing. Ngayon ay tatalakayin natin ang klasikal
na repetition code na siyang pundasyon ng ating unang quantum error correcting code: ang siyam na qubit Shore code na
makikita natin sa lalong madaling panahon. Ang mga repetition code ay mga pangunahing halimbawa ng mga error correcting code
ang ideya ay maaari nating protektahan ang mga bit laban sa mga pagkakamali sa pamamagitan lamang ng pag-uulit ng bawat bit nang ilang beses. Sa partikular, tingnan natin ang
three-bit repetition code. Dito ay ine-encode natin ang isang bit sa tatlo sa pamamagitan lamang ng pag-uulit ng bit nang tatlong beses kaya
ang zero ay ine-encode bilang 000 at ang isa ay ine-encode bilang 111. Siyempre kung walang nangyaring mali ay
madali nating matukoy ang dalawang posibilidad. Ngunit kung may pagkakamali at isang bit ay lumipat, sabihin nating
ang zero ay nagiging isa o ang isa ay nagiging zero, maaari pa rin nating malaman kung ano ang orihinal na bit
sa pamamagitan ng pagtingin kung alin sa dalawang binary na halaga ang lumabas nang dalawang beses. Katumbas nito ay maaari tayong mag-decode sa pamamagitan ng pagkalkula ng majority na halaga
o sa ibang salita ang binary na halagang laging lumalabas nang pinaka-madalas. At hindi mahirap makita na
kung mayroon tayong pinakamaraming isang bit flip na pagkakamali ay magiging tama ang pag-decode. Siyempre kung dalawa ang lumipat na bit o kung
lahat ng tatlong bit ay lumipat ay hindi ito gagana at makakakuha tayo ng maling halaga kapag nag-decode tayo. At iyan ay isang pangkalahatang katangian
na tinatangkilik ng bawat error correcting code. Maaaring makaituwid ka ng ilang pagkakamali ngunit hindi mo kailanman mapapatawad ang bawat pagkakamali. At sa huli ito ay tungkol sa
pagbabawas ng pagkakataon ng pagkakamali kumpara sa pagtitiyak ng kawastuhan na kung saan ay karaniwang hindi
posible. Bilang halimbawa ng isang sitwasyon kung saan maaari nating bawasan ang pagkakataon ng pagkakamali, ipagpalagay nating ang ating
layunin ay makipag-communicate ng isang bit sa isang hypothetical na tatanggap at para gawin ito ay kaya nating magpadala ng mga bit sa pamamagitan ng isang
tinatawag na binary symmetric Channel na bumabago ng bawat bit na ipinadala nito nang malaya nang may ilang probabilidad
P. Kaya na may probabilidad na 1 minus P ang tatanggap ay makakatanggap ng anumang bit na nilayon nating ipadala ngunit na may probabilidad P
ang bit ay lumilipat at ang tatanggap ay nakakakuha ng kabaligtaran ng kahit anong ipinadala natin. Kaya kung hindi natin gagamitin ang repetition
code at sa halip ay direkta na ipadala ang bit na nasa isip natin sa pamamagitan ng channel ang tatanggap ay makakakuha ng maling bit nang may
probabilidad P. Sa kabilang banda kung i-encode muna natin ang bit na gusto nating ipadala gamit ang three-bit repetition code at
pagkatapos ay ipadala ang bawat isa sa tatlong bit ng encoding sa pamamagitan ng channel, ang bawat isa sa kanila ay lilipat nang may probabilidad P kaya
ang posibilidad ng isang bit flip ay mas malaki na ngayon dahil mayroon nang tatlong bit na maaaring lumipat kaysa sa isa
ngunit kung pinakamaraming isang bit ang lumipat ang tatanggap ay makakatama sa pag-decode. Kaya makakakuha lamang tayo ng pagkakamali pagkatapos ng
pag-decode kung dalawa o higit pang bit ang lumipat sa panahon ng pagpapadala at hindi masyadong mahirap kalkulahin na mangyayari ito nang may
probabilidad na 3 * P^2 - 2 * P^3. Para sa mga halaga ng P na mas maliit kaysa 1/12
nagdudulot ito ng pagbaba sa probabilidad na ang tatanggap ay makakakuha ng maling bit. Maaari pa ring may pagkakataon ng pagkakamali sa kasong ito ngunit ang
code ay nagpapababa ng posibilidad nito. At kung gusto mong bawasan pa ang pagkakataon maaari mong gawin iyon gamit ang
ibang code kasama ngunit hindi limitado sa posibilidad ng paggamit ng repetition code kung saan ang naka-encode na bit ay iniuulit
nang higit sa tatlong beses. Para sa mga halaga ng P na mas malaki kaysa 1/12 sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang code ay talagang nagpapalala ng
mga bagay sa kahulugang nagdadagdag ito sa posibilidad na ang tatanggap ay makakakuha ng maling bit. Kaya tiyak na hindi natin gagamitin ang code na ito sa
sitwasyong iyon. Ang three-bit repetition code ay isang klasikal na error correcting code ngunit maaari rin nating isaalang-alang kung ano ang mangyayari kung
susubukan nating gamitin ito upang protektahan ang mga qubit laban sa mga pagkakamali. Hindi ito napakagandang quantum error correcting code tulad ng makikita natin
maaari itong ituwid ang ilang mga pagkakamali ngunit pinapalala nito ang iba pang mga pagkakamali. Ito ay ang unang hakbang patungo sa Shore
code kaya tingnan natin kung paano ito gumagana para sa mga qubit. Una, upang maging malinaw kapag tinutukoy natin ang 3-bit repetition code na ginagamit
para sa mga qubit ang naiisip natin ay isang encoding ng isang qubit tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen kung saan ang Alpha 0 plus beta 1 ay
ine-encode bilang Alpha 000 plus beta 111 o sa ibang salita ang standard basis state
ay iniuulit nang tatlong beses. Pansinin na ito ay hindi katulad ng pag-uulit ng quantum state nang tatlong beses tulad ng isang partikular na
quantum state S na ine-encode bilang S tensor S tensor S na hindi isang encoding na magagawa natin
para sa isang hindi kilalang quantum state S ayon sa no-cloning theorem. Ang encoding na tinutukoy natin
sa kabilang banda ay napakadaling ipatupad. Narito ang isang napakasimpleng quantum circuit na ginagawa ito gamit ang dalawang initialized na workspace qubit at dalawang
controlled-NOT gate. Ngayon ipagpalagay nating nagkaroon ng pagkakamali pagkatapos maisagawa ang encoding
at sa partikular, ipagpalagay nating ang isang Pauli-X na operasyon o sa ibang salita isang bit flip ay nangyayari sa isa sa
mga qubit. At sa figure na ito ay ang gitnang qubit. Siyempre ito ay hindi lamang uri ng pagkakamali na maaaring mangyari at maaaring
tumutol ka sa ideya na ang isang pagkakamali ay kumukuha ng anyo ng perpektong unitary na operasyong ito ngunit babalikan natin ito sa ibang pagkakataon sa aralin at sa ngayon ay maaari
nating isipin ito bilang isang halimbawa lamang. Narito ang resulta ng estado. Ito ay katulad ng orihinal na encoding
maliban na ang gitnang bit sa loob ng bawat ket ay lumipat. Malinaw na makita ito mula sa mga mathematical na pagpapahayag para sa estado
ngunit ipagpalagay na mayroon lamang tayong tatlong qubit at pinaghihinalaan natin na maaaring nangyari ang isang bit flip ngunit hindi natin alam kung aling qubit ang maaaring
naapektuhan. Isang paraan upang malaman kung nagkaroon ng bit flip ay ang magsagawa ng standard basis measurement at suriin ang resulta. Sa kasong ito makikita natin
ang alinman sa 010 o 110 na may mga probabilidad na depende sa Alpha at beta at sa alinmang kaso ang ating konklusyon
ay ang gitnang bit ay lumipat. Ngunit sa kasamaang palad, winawasak nito ang orihinal na quantum state at ang estadong
ito ay mahalaga sa atin. Pagkatapos ng lahat ang buong punto ay protektahan ang quantum state na ito. Kaya ito ay hindi isang magandang
opsyon. Ang magagawa natin sa halip ay gamitin ang quantum circuit na ipinapakita dito sa screen kung saan isinasalud natin ang naka-encode na estado
sa tuktok na tatlong qubit. Mahalagang ang circuit ay nagkakalkula ng parity ng standard
basis state para sa tuktok na dalawang qubit pati na rin para sa ilalim na dalawang qubit ng encoding at ito ay magpapakita ng
lokasyon ng bit flip. Sa partikular sa kasong ito ay makakakuha tayo ng resulta ng isa para sa parehong parity check na ito at mula sa
impormasyong iyon ay maaari nating tapusin na ang gitnang bit ang nagkaiba sa isa pa. Kaya malinaw na iyon ang lumipat
at kakaibang hindi ito nagdudulot ng pagguho ng estado. Kaya mayroon na tayong pagkakataon na subukang ituwid ang bit
flip upang sa huli ay marahil ay ma-decode tayo at makuha ang ating orihinal na estado. Babalikan natin ang pagtutuwid
sa sandali ngunit una, maikling isaalang-alang natin ang iba pang mga posibilidad para sa isang bit flip na pagkakamali. Kung sa halip ang bit flip na pagkakamali
ay nangyari sa ibaba o kaliwang qubit ay makakakuha tayo ng resulta ng isa zero na binabasa mula sa ibaba pataas at muli
ang estado ay hindi magbabago. At kung ang bit flip ay nangyari sa tuktok na qubit ang output ay magiging
01 at muli naman ang estado ay hindi nagbabago. At sa pamamagitan ng paraan kung walang
bit flip na pagkakamali ang resulta ng sukat ay 00 at muli ang estado ay lalabas na hindi nagbago
Kaya buod-buurin natin ang lahat ng ito sa anyo ng isang talahanayan kung saan ilista natin ang bawat isa sa mga posibleng estado na nakukuha natin mula sa pinakamaraming isang bit flip ang sukat
na mga resulta na tinutukoy natin bilang syndrome sa konteksto ng pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali at ang pagtutuwid na kailangan nating gawin upang makuha ang orihinal
na encoding. Kung walang pagkakamali ang syndrome ay 00 at walang kailangang gawin upang ayusin ang
estado. Kung ang ibaba o pinakakaliwang qubit ay nakaranas ng bit flip ang syndrome ay 10 at ang angkop na pagtutuwid
ay ang mag-apply ng X gate sa ibaba o pinakakaliwang qubit at ang dalawang kaso ay
katulad. Kaya kung i-apply natin ang angkop na pagtutuwid batay sa syndrome ay matitiyak nating mabawi ang orihinal
na encoding sa lahat ng apat na kaso. Muli, isinasaalang-alang lamang natin ang posibilidad na pinakamaraming isang bit
flip na pagkakamali ang nangyari. Hindi ito gagana nang tama kung dalawa o tatlong bit ang lumipat at hindi rin natin isinaalang-alang ang
posibilidad ng iba pang mga pagkakamali. Ngayon isaalang-alang natin ang ibang uri ng pagkakamali. Sa quantum na setting ang bit
flip na mga pagkakamali ay hindi lamang ang mga pagkakamaling kailangan nating pangalagaan. Halimbawa, kailangan din nating pangalagaan ang phase flip
na mga pagkakamali o phase flip lamang kung iksi na, na inilalarawan ng Z gate o katumbas nito ng Pauli-Z
na mga operasyon. Sa kasamaang palad ang three-bit repetition code ay ganap na nabigo sa pagtuklas ng mga phase flip. Halimbawa, ipagpalagay na
ine-encode natin ang isang qubit gamit ang 3-bit repetition code tulad ng dati at nagkaroon ng phase flip na pagkakamali sa gitnang
qubit. Makukuha natin ang estado na ipinapakita sa screen na eksaktong ang encoding na makukuha natin kung ang
phase flip ay nangyari sa orihinal na qubit bago tayo nag-encode. Kaya kung gagawin natin ang katulad na
circuit tulad ng dati upang subukang matuklas ang isang pagkakamali ay makakakuha tayo ng syndrome 00 na maling nagmumungkahi na walang nangyaring pagkakamali
Kaya ang 3-bit repetition code ay gumagana para sa pinakamaraming isang bit flip na pagkakamali ngunit nabibigo itong matuklas ang mga phase flip na pagkakamali
sa katunayan pinapalala pa nito ang mga bagay sa ilang kahulugan dahil ngayon ay mayroon na tayong tatlong beses na mas maraming qubit na maaaring makaranas ng phase flip
na mga pagkakamali. Napansin natin na ang three-bit repetition code ay ganap na walang malay sa mga phase flip na pagkakamali kaya hindi ito mukhang
nakakatulong sa pagharap sa uri ng pagkakamaling ito. Ngunit sa katunayan maaari nating baguhin ang three-bit repetition code upang ito ay
makatuklas ng mga phase flip na pagkakamali at ipapaliwanag ko ngayon kung paano ito magagawa. Narito ang orihinal na circuit para sa
pag-encode ng isang qubit gamit ang 3-bit repetition code at ang paraan ng pagbabago nito ay napaka-simple. I-apply lamang natin ang isang
Hadamard gate sa bawat qubit ng encoding. Ang isang Hadamard gate ay ginagawang plus state ang zero state at isang
minus state ang one state. Kaya ang net effect ay makukuha natin ang estado na ipinapakita sa screen kung saan ang ket
|+++ at |--- ay pinaikling notasyon para sa tensor ng tatlong plus state o tatlong minus
state. Ang isang phase flip na pagkakamali o sa ibang salita ang isang Z gate ay ginagawang minus state ang mga plus state at ginagawang plus state ang mga minus state
Kaya ang encoding na ito ay magiging kapaki-pakinabang para sa pagtuklas at pagwawasto ng mga phase flip na pagkakamali at para gawin iyon ay maaari
nating baguhin ang circuit sa pagtuklas ng pagkakamali mula kanina sa sumusunod na paraan. Narito ang circuit mula kanina at ang gagawin natin ay
ilagay lamang ang mga Hadamard gate sa simula at sa dulo tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen
Ang ideya ay napaka-simple. Ang unang tatlong Hadamard gate ay ginagawang zero at one state muli ang mga plus at minus state. Ang
katulad na mga parity check tulad ng dati ay nagaganap at pagkatapos ang ikalawang layer ng Hadamard gate ay nagbabalik sa atin
sa ating encoding. Isa pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol dito ay ang pangunahing ginagawa nating pag-convert ng mga phase flip na pagkakamali sa bit flip na mga Pagkakamali sa pamamagitan ng conjugation ng Hadamard
na mga operasyon. Maaari sa pamamagitan ng paraan na pasimplehin natin ang circuit nang kaunti. Ang circuit na ito ay ganap na katumbas
at maaari mong tingnan ito sa iyong sarili kung gusto mo. Kaya kung ilagay natin ang ating naka-encode na qubit sa circuit na ito na inaakalang
walang nangyaring phase flip na pagkakamali ay makukuha natin ang syndrome 00 na nagpapahiwatig na walang phase flip
na mga pagkakamali. At kung mayroon tayong phase flip na pagkakamali sa tuktok na qubit, sabihin nating, ang pinakakanang mga plus at minus ay lumalipat
at nagdudulot ng ibang error syndrome na 01 sa kasong ito na nagtatukoy ng lokasyon ng phase flip tulad ng katulad
na nakuha natin para sa bit flip. Maaari nating ituwid ito sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng Z gate sa tuktok na qubit at ang sitwasyon
ay katulad para sa mga phase flip na pagkakamali sa alinman sa dalawang qubit. Kaya maaari nating matuklas at
ituwid ang hanggang isang phase flip na pagkakamali gamit ang code na ito. Ngunit sa kasamaang palad tulad ng maaaring nahulaan mo ay hindi na natin maaaring
ituwid ang mga bit flip na pagkakamali. Gayunpaman ay wala tayong mawawala dahil maaari nating pagsamahin ang dalawang code na ito
upang makakuha ng code na makakaituwid ng parehong bit flip at phase flip na mga pagkakamali. At sa katunayan ito ay magagawa
ituwid ang anumang pagkakamali sa isang qubit. Ngayon ay panahon na upang talakayin ang 9 qubit Shore code na isang Quantum
error correcting code na maaari nating makuha sa pamamagitan ng pagsasama ng dalawang code na nakita natin kamakailan, ibig sabihin ang three-bit
repetition code na nagpapahintulot sa atin na ituwid ang isang bit flip na pagkakamali at ang binagong bersyon ng code na iyon na nagpapahintulot sa atin na ituwid ang isang phase flip na pagkakamali
Upang maging mas tumpak, ang 9 qubit Shore code ay ang code na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-concatenate ng dalawang code na nangangahulugang
unang nag-a-apply tayo ng isang encoding na nag-e-encode ng isang qubit sa tatlo at pagkatapos ay i-apply natin ang isa pang encoding sa bawat isa sa
tatlong qubit nang hiwalay. Kaya makakakuha tayo ng siyam na qubit sa kabuuan. Maaari nating ipahayag ito sa anyo ng isang
circuit diagram tulad ng sumusunod. Una, i-apply natin ang binagong bersyon ng 3-bit repetition code
na nagtutuklas ng mga phase flip na pagkakamali at pagkatapos ay ie-encode natin ang bawat isa sa mga nagresultang qubit nang hiwalay gamit ang orihinal
na 3-bit repetition code. Kaya kung paliitan natin ang circuit na ito nang kaunti upang gumawa ng karagdagang espasyo ay maaari
nating tukuyin ang code sa medyo iba't ibang mga termino sa pamamagitan ng paglalarawan kung paano ang dalawang standard basis state para sa ating orihinal na qubit ay
ine-encode. At kapag nalaman na natin ito ay matutukoy natin sa pamamagitan ng linearity kung paano ine-encode ang arbitrary na qubit state vector
Kaya iyon ang 9 qubit Shore code at ang ideya ay ang isa sa mga code ay nagpapahintulot sa atin na ituwid ang phase flip
na mga pagkakamali at ang isa pang code ay nagpapahintulot sa atin na ituwid ang mga bit flip na pagkakamali at tulad ng makikita natin ay sa katunayan magpapahiwatig ito na kaya nating
ituwid ang arbitrary na pagkakamali sa isang qubit. Ngayon tingnan natin kung paano natin matutuklas at maitatuwid ang mga pagkakamali gamit ang 9 qubit
Shore code simula sa mga bit flip na pagkakamali na tinatawag ding X na mga pagkakamali. Narito ang circuit na gumaganap ng
encoding at upang mas madali ang pag-uusap ay iisipin natin ang siyam na qubit na nakuha natin mula sa code na ito bilang
nakagrupo sa tatlong bloke ng tatlong qubit kung saan ang bawat bloke ay kumakatawan sa encoding na nakuha natin mula sa pag-apply ng
pangalawang hakbang ng encoding na siyang ordinaryong 3-bit repetition code. Iyon ang tinatawag na inner code sa
kontekstong ito. Samantalang ang outer code ay ang code na ginamit para sa unang hakbang ng encoding na sa kasong ito ay ang binagong
bersyon ng three-bit repetition code na gumagana para sa mga phase flip na pagkakamali. Upang ituwid ang mga bit flip na pagkakamali ay maaari
nating tratuhin ang bawat isa sa mga bloke nang hiwalay. Ang bawat bloke ay isang encoding ng isang qubit gamit ang three-bit repetition
code at ang code na iyon ay nagpoprotekta laban sa mga bit flip na pagkakamali. Ipagpalagay muna na ang isang X na pagkakamali ay nangyayari sa alinman sa mga qubit
tulad ng gitnang qubit sa gitnang bloke. Kung hiwalay nating sinusuri ang bawat bloke para sa mga bit flip na pagkakamali at
inaaayos ang anumang pagkakamaling natuklasan natin ay maitatuwid ang pagkakamaling ito at mabawi ang orihinal na encoding
Sa katunayan maaari rin tayong magkaroon ng maraming X na pagkakamali at mapanatili pa rin ang pagwawasto sa ganitong paraan basta ang mga pagkakamali ay nasa
magkakahiwalay na mga bloke. Kung mayroon tayong dalawa o tatlong X na pagkakamali sa isang bloke ay may problema tayo ngunit
hangga't mayroon pang pinakamaraming isang X na pagkakamali bawat bloke ang inner code ay mahuhuli ang mga ito at mabawi natin ang orihinal na naka-encode
na estado. Kaya ang pagwawasto ng mga bit flip na pagkakamali ay medyo simpleng bagay para sa code na ito. Kailangan din nating isaalang-alang ang mga phase flip na pagkakamali
o sa ibang salita ang mga Z na pagkakamali. Sa pagkakataong ito ay hindi masyadong malinaw kung ano ang dapat gawin natin dahil ang outer code ang isa
na nagtatama ng mga phase flip na pagkakamali ngunit hindi natin direktang matutuklas at maitatuwid ang mga ito dahil ang inner code ay parang nakahadlang sa
daan ngunit makikita natin kung paano ito gagawin sa lalong madaling panahon. Upang mas maipaunawa kung paano gumagana ang X at Z
na mga pagkakamali at ang mga epekto na mayroon ang mga ito sa loob ng mga quantum circuit ay nakakatulong na mapansin ang ilang simpleng relasyon sa pagitan ng mga pagkakamaling ito at ng mga C
NOT gate at ito ay magiging kapaki-pakinabang din sa susunod na aralin. Una, simulan natin sa mga X na pagkakamali
o mga X gate at kung paano sila nauugnay sa mga C NOT gate. Kung mag-apply tayo ng X gate sa
target qubit ng isang C NOT gate at pagkatapos ay i-apply ang C NOT, katumbas ito ng pagpapalit ng pagkakasunud-sunod at paggawa muna ng C NOT
Sa kabilang banda kung mag-apply tayo ng X gate sa control qubit ng isang C NOT gate at pagkatapos ay i-apply ang C NOT ay hindi natin simpleng
mapapalitan ang pagkakasunud-sunod ngunit sa halip ay kailangan nating i-apply ang X gate sa parehong qubit at maaari mong tingnan ang lahat ng relasyong ito sa
iyong sarili kung gusto mo sa pamamagitan ng pag-iisip kung ano ang mangyayari sa mga standard basis state. Halimbawa, ang sitwasyon ay katulad para sa Z
na mga pagkakamali maliban na ang mga tungkulin ng control at target qubit ay nagpapalit. Sa partikular kung magsasagawa tayo ng isang
Z gate sa control qubit ng isang C NOT gate at pagkatapos ay isagawa ang C NOT ay may katulad na epekto iyon sa pagsasagawa ng
Z gate pagkatapos ng C NOT. Ngunit kung isasagawa natin ang Z gate sa target qubit sa halip ay katumbas iyon
ng pagsasagawa muna ng C NOT at pagkatapos ay pag-apply ng Z gate sa parehong qubit. At sa huli, lahat ng
relasyon na ito ay simetrikal sa kahulugang palagi nating mapapalitan ang pagkakasunud-sunod ng mga gate sa magkabilang panig ng bawat equation
na katumbas ng pagkuha ng inverse o conjugate transpose ng magkabilang panig dahil ang mga X, Z at C NOT
gate ay lahat ng kanilang sariling inverse. Ngayon isaalang-alang natin ang mga phase flip na pagkakamali at kung paano natin matutuklas at maitatuwid
ang mga ito gamit ang 9 qubit Shore code. Narito ang ating encoding circuit at patuloy nating iisipin ang siyam
na qubit na ginagamit sa encoding bilang nakagrupo sa tatlong bloke ng tatlong qubit. Ipagpalagay na ang isang Z na pagkakamali ay nangyayari sa
alinman sa mga qubit tulad ng isa na ipinahiwatig dito. Gamit ang naobserbahan natin kamakailan tungkol sa Z
gate at C NOT gate, katumbas iyon ng dalawang Z na pagkakamali bago ang C NOT: isa sa
control at isa sa target qubit. At ang mga pagkakamaling ito ay nagkataong commute sa isa pang C NOT sa bloke kaya
maaari nating palitan ang pagkakasunud-sunod at narito ang nakuha natin. Ang mas mababang Z na pagkakamali ay walang ginagawa dahil kumikilos ito sa isang zero
state at maaari nating i-slide ang lahat ng iba pa at makuha ang diagram na ito. Kaya ang natuklasan natin ay ang isang Z na pagkakamali kahit saan sa loob ng
gitnang bloke ay katumbas ng isang Z na pagkakamali na nangyayari sa gitnang qubit bago ang pangalawang yugto ng encoding at
maaari mong gamitin ang eksaktong katulad na pangangatwiran para sa isang Z na pagkakamali sa alinman sa mga qubit. Ang isang phase flip sa alinmang qubit sa loob ng isang bloke
ay katumbas ng isang phase flip sa kaukulang qubit bago ang inner encoding at iyon ay halos simple at intuitive kung
iniisip mo kung paano nakakaapekto ang mga Z na pagkakamali sa three-bit repetition code. Kaya ang isang opsyon para sa pagharap sa isang Z
na pagkakamali ay ang i-decode ang inner code at pagkatapos ay tumuklas at ituwid ang mga Z na pagkakamali gamit ang outer code na siyang binagong
bersyon ng 3-bit repetition code na makakaituwid ng isang Z na pagkakamali. Kaya naitutuwid ang ating Z na pagkakamali at
maaari nating i-re-encode gamit ang inner code kung gusto nating gawin iyon. Maaari rin nating ituwid ang mga Z na pagkakamali
nang in-place, kung baga, nang hindi nag-dede-decode at nag-re-reencoding at medyo simple ito ngunit upang ipaliwanag kung paano
natin ito magagawa ay kailangan natin ng kaunti pang espasyo. Ipagpalagay na ini-decode natin ang inner code
at pagkatapos ay kinakalkula natin ang syndrome para sa outer code gamit ang katulad na pamamaraan tulad ng dati kung saan kasama lamang natin ang tatlong qubit mula sa outer code at
pagkatapos ay nag-re-reencoding tayo. Maaari nating pasimplehin ang lahat ng mga C NOT na ito nang kaunti at sa katunayan
maaari nating gamitin ang mga relasyon sa pagitan ng NOT gate at C NOT gate na naobserbahan natin kamakailan upang makatulong sa
gawaing iyon. At sa pamamagitan ng paggawa nito ay makakatipid tayo ng apat na C NOT at ito ang circuit na makukuha natin. Kung naganap ang isang Z na pagkakamali sa isa sa
mga qubit, ang sinasabi ng syndrome sa atin ngayon ay hindi kung aling qubit ang nakaranas ng Z na pagkakamali kundi kung aling bloke ang nangyariang Z na pagkakamali
ngunit ayos lang iyon dahil alam natin na hindi mahalaga kung aling qubit sa loob ng isang bloke ang nakaranas ng Z na pagkakamali: ang
epekto ay pareho para sa lahat ng tatlong qubit sa loob ng bloke. Kaya maaari nating ituwid ang Z na pagkakamali sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng Z gate sa alinman sa
mga qubit sa loob ng bloke na iyon. Ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay isang halimbawa ng tinatawag na degeneracy sa isang error
correcting code kung saan hindi natin natatukoy nang natatangi ang isang partikular na pagkakamali ngunit kaya nating ituwid ito. Sa huli, ipagpalagay nating parehong isang
bit flip at isang phase flip na pagkakamali ay nangyayari, posible sa parehong qubit. Halimbawa, ipagpalagay na ang isang
bit flip at isang phase flip na pagkakamali ay nangyayari sa qubit na ito. Tulad ng lumalabas, ang mga pagkakamaling ito ay maaaring
matuklas at maituwid nang ganap na hiwalay at sa katunayan hindi mahalaga kung itatama natin ang bawat bloke para sa isang
bit flip muna at pagkatapos ay ituwid ang mga phase flip o kung gagawin natin ito nang kabaligtaran. Upang makita ito, unang pansinin natin
na ang pagkakasunud-sunod ng mga pagkakamaling ito ay hindi mahalaga kaya maaari nating baguhin ang kanilang pagkakasunud-sunod kung gusto natin. Ang dahilan para doon ay hindi dahil
nagco-commute ang X at Z dahil hindi sila nagco-commute: X * Z ay katumbas ng negatibong Z * X ngunit ang
negatibong 1 na factor ay walang epekto sa sitwasyong ito dahil ito ay isang global phase. Maaari na nating ilipat ang Z na pagkakamali tulad ng
dati at sa puntong ito ay malinaw na kung muna nating itutuwid ang bawat bloke para sa mga X na pagkakamali at pagkatapos ay itatama natin
ang mga Z na pagkakamali ay maitatuwid na natin ang parehong mga pagkakamali. Bilang kahalili, kung sa ilang kadahilanan
ay nagpasya tayong ituwid muna ang mga Z na pagkakamali ay magagawa natin iyon at ang X na pagkakamali ay ganap na walang epekto sa prosesong iyon
at dapat na totoong iyon dahil una ang X na pagkakamali ay nagco-commute sa bawat isang gate sa circuit na nagkakalkula ng
syndrome para sa outer code at pangalawa ang pagkakasunud-sunod sa pagitan ng X na pagkakamali at ng Z gate na ina-apply natin upang gawin ang
pagtutuwid ay hindi mahalaga tulad ng ipinagtatalo natin nang ang Z gate ay isang pagkakamali. Kaya nagpapahintulot iyon sa pagtutuwid ng Z
na pagkakamali at pagkatapos ay maaari nating ituwid ang bawat bloke upang alisin ang X na pagkakamali. Kaya ang ipinagtatalo natin ay maaari
nating ituwid ang isang X na pagkakamali, isang Z na pagkakamali, o pareho sa alinman sa mga qubit gamit ang code na ito
sa katunayan maaari tayong magtuwid ng mas maraming pagkakamali kaysa doon tulad ng maraming X na pagkakamali basta naaabot ang mga ito sa iba't ibang bloke
o maraming Z na pagkakamali basta pinakamaraming isang bloke ang makakakuha ng kakaibang bilang ng mga ito. Ngunit ang pinaka-kaugnay sa pasulong ay
ang maaari nating ituwid ang isang X na pagkakamali, isang Z na pagkakamali, o pareho sa alinmang isang qubit at sa huling bahagi ng aralin
ay makikita natin kung paano ito sa katunayan ay sapat na upang tapusin na ang code na ito ay makakaituwid ng arbitrary na pagkakamali sa alinmang isang
qubit. Bago tayo lumipat sa huling bahagi ng aralin kung saan isinasaalang-alang natin ang arbitrary na quantum na mga pagkakamali ay maikling
isaalang-alang natin ang performance ng 9 qubit Shore code kapag ang mga pagkakamaling kinakatawan ng mga Pauli matrix ay nangyayari nang random sa
mga qubit. Upang maging mas kongkreto, isaalang-alang natin ang isang simpleng noise model kung saan ang mga pagkakamali ay nangyayari nang hiwalay sa mga qubit
na ang bawat qubit ay nakakaranas ng pagkakamali nang may probabilidad P at walang kaugnayan sa pagitan ng mga pagkakamali sa iba't ibang
qubit. Ang pinakamasamang sitwasyon para sa 9 qubit Shore code ay ang isang Y na pagkakamali o sa ibang salita parehong X na pagkakamali at Z na
pagkakamali ay nangyayari sa bawat apektadong qubit at iaakalain natin ang pinakamasamang sitwasyong ito para lamang sa layunin ng pagkuha ng hangganan
sa performance ng code. Ngunit maaari rin nating isaalang-alang halimbawa na ang tatlong Pauli na pagkakamali ay pantay-pantay
na malamang. Ngayon ipagpalagay na ang Q ay isang qubit sa ilang partikular na estado na nais nating protektahan laban sa mga pagkakamali at isipin na
mayroon tayong pagpipilian na gamitin ang 9 qubit Shore code. Dapat ba nating gamitin ito? Ang sagot ay hindi kinakailangan
oo dahil kung masyadong maraming ingay o sa ibang salita ang P ay masyadong malaki ang paggamit ng Shore code ay maaaring talagang magpalala ng mga bagay
tulad ng nakuha natin para sa repetition code kapag ang P ay mas malaki kaysa sa 1/2. Ngunit kung ang P ay sapat na maliit ay
oo ang sagot ay dapat nating gamitin ang code. Kaya tingnan natin kung bakit ito ganoon at ano ang ibig sabihin ng P na masyadong malaki o sapat na maliit
para sa code na ito. Ang Shore code ay makakaituwid ng anumang Pauli na pagkakamali sa isang qubit at sa pinakamasama
na kaso kung saan ang mga Pauli na pagkakamali ay mga Y na pagkakamali nangangahulugang ito na ang code ay matagumpay na nagpoprotekta sa Q nang may probabilidad na ibinigay ng
pagpapahayag na ipinapakita sa screen. Partikular, gumagana ang code kapag walang mga pagkakamali at nangyayari iyon
nang may probabilidad na 1 minus P^9 dahil may siyam na qubit na kailangan ng bawat isa ay hindi naapektuhan. At gumagana ito kapag mayroon
eksaktong isang pagkakamali at isinasaalang-alang na mayroon siyam na iba't ibang qubit na maaaring apektado ay nangyayari ito nang may probabilidad na 9 * P * (1 - P)^8
Sa kabilang banda kung hindi tayo nag-abala na gumamit ng code ang ating isa at tanging qubit ay hindi maapektuhan ng isang pagkakamali nang may
probabilidad na 1 minus P. Kaya ang code ay nakakatulong lamang kapag ang unang probabilidad ay mas malaki kaysa sa pangalawa
dahil ang mga Expresyon na ito ay kumakatawan sa ating mga probabilidad ng tagumpay sa dalawang kaso kapag ginamit natin ang code at kapag
hindi natin ginamit. Narito ang isang plot ng dalawang function na ito para sa maliliit na halaga ng P at natuklasan natin na ang break even na punto ay nangyayari sa
halos 3 at 3/4 na porsyento. Kaya kung ang P ay mas maliit kaysa sa halagang ito ay nakakatulong ang code
Sa break even na punto ay pantay ang mga probabilidad kaya sayang lamang ang ating oras kasama ang 8 qubit kung
gagamitin natin ang code ngunit kung hindi man ay walang masama at lampas sa puntong iyon ay talagang hindi dapat nating gamitin ang code na ito
dahil talagang pinapataas nito ang pagkakataon ng isang pagkakamali sa naka-encode na qubit na karaniwang tinutukoy natin bilang
logical qubit sa kontekstong ito at nangyayari iyon dahil lamang sa ang pagkakataon ng dalawa o higit pang mga pagkakamali sa siyam na qubit ay
mas malaki kaysa sa pagkakataon ng isang pagkakamali sa isang qubit para sa mga halaga ng P sa hanay na ito. Ang 3 at 3/4% ay maaaring hindi mukhang napaka-
maganda lalo na kumpara sa 50% na siyang katulad na break even na punto para sa three-bit repetition code para sa
klasikal na impormasyon. Ngunit mas mahirap protektahan ang quantum na impormasyon at bukod pa rito, bagaman ang
code na ito ay kumakatawan sa isang maliwanag na natuklasan bilang ang pinaka-unang quantum error correcting code at kahanga-hanga ito para sa mga layuning pedagohikal ang katotohanan ng
bagay ay hindi ito napakagandang code sa mga praktikal na termino. Sa ngayon ay isinaalang-alang natin ang mga X na pagkakamali
at mga Z na pagkakamali sa konteksto ng 9 qubit Shore code. Ngayon isaalang-alang natin ang mga arbitrary na pagkakamali
simula muna sa mga unitary na pagkakamali. Halimbawa, ang ganitong pagkakamali ay maaaring tumutugma sa isang napaka-maliit
na pag-ikot ng Bloch sphere na posibleng kumakatawan sa isang pagkakamaling nagmumula sa isang gate na hindi perpekto halimbawa
o maaari itong anumang iba pang unitary na operasyon sa isang qubit at hindi kinakailangan isang bagay na malapit sa identity
na operasyon. Maaaring mukhang mahirap ang pagwawasto ng mga ganitong pagkakamali. Mayroong walang hanggang maraming posibleng pagkakamali tulad
nito at hindi maiisip na maaari nating tukuyin nang eksakto kung ano ang pagkakamali at pagkatapos ay i-undo ito. Ngunit hindi
natin talagang kailangang gumawa ng anumang naiiba mula sa tinalakay natin basta maitutuwid natin ang isang bit flip, isang phase flip, o pareho ay
sa katunayan magtatagumpay tayo sa pagwawasto ng arbitrary na single qubit unitary na pagkakamali at ipapaliwanag ko ngayon kung bakit iyon
Muna, tulad ng lahat ng 2x2 matrix ay maaari nating ipahayag ang isang arbitrary na unitary Matrix
na kumakatawan sa isang pagkakamali sa isang qubit bilang linear na kombinasyon ng apat na Pauli matrix kasama ang identity
Matrix. At sa pamamagitan ng paraan tulad ng maaaring napansin mo ay gumagamit ako ng malaking X, Y at Z upang tukuyin ang mga hindi-identity na Pauli matrix
at patuloy ko iyon sa natitirang bahagi ng serye. Iyon ay kaugalian sa quantum na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali at nagpapadali rin ito ng
pag-basa ng mga bagay sa kontekstong ito. Magiging kapaki-pakinabang din na gumamit ng mga subscript upang ipahiwatig kung aling
qubit ang isang partikular na qubit unitary na operasyon na kumikilos. Halimbawa kung gagamit tayo ng numerasyon ng qubit ni Qiskit
simula sa qubit zero sa kanan ay mayroon tayong mga pagpapahayag na ipinapakita sa screen para sa
iba't ibang unitary na operasyon sa mga single qubit kung saan sa bawat kaso ay tine-tensor natin ang unitary Matrix sa identity Matrix
sa bawat iba pang qubit. Kaya sa partikular ay maaari nating ipahayag ang UK ibig sabihin U na inilapat sa qubit K bilang katulad na
linear na kombinasyon tulad ng dati maliban na ang bawat Pauli Matrix ay inilapat sa qubit K. Hindi natin kailangang mag-abala sa
subscript para sa identity sa pamamagitan ng paraan. Ang pagkakaunawa dito ay ito ang identity sa lahat ng
qubit. Ngayon ipagpalagay na ang |ψ⟩ ay ang 9 qubit encoding ng isang qubit state. Kung ang pagkakamali U ay nangyayari sa
qubit k ay makukuha natin ang U_k * |ψ⟩ na maaari nating ipahayag bilang linear na kombinasyon ng mga Pauli na operasyon na kumikilos sa |ψ⟩ na siyempre
ay |ψ⟩ lamang sa kaso ng identity. Sa puntong ito ay magiging kapaki-pakinabang na pansinin na ang Pauli Y
Matrix ay katumbas ng i * X * Z kaya maaari nating gawin ang substitusyon na iyon sa ating
pagpapahayag. Kaya naganap ang pagkakamaling ito at ngayon ipagpalagay na sinusubukan nating ituwid ito gamit ang katulad na pamamaraan tulad ng
para sa unang hakbang ay ang kalkulahin ang syndrome na sa kaso ng Shore code ay 8 bit ang haba: dalawang bit para sa bawat isa sa
tatlong beses na ginagamit natin ang inner code kasama ang karagdagang dalawang bit para sa outer code. Ngunit hindi talaga mahalaga iyon, maaari nating isipin ito bilang
ilang fixed na haba na string. Narito ang paglalarawan ng estado na nakukuha natin nang eksakto bago ang sukat ng syndrome kung saan ang bawat
syndrome ay anumang walo bit na nakukuha natin mula sa kaukulang Pauli na pagkakamali. Pansinin sa puntong ito na ang dalawa
na sistema ay correlated sa pangkalahatan at ito talaga ang susi sa pagpapatakbo ng lahat ng ito. Sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat ng syndrome ay
epektibo nating gagawin ang pag-collapse ng estado sa isa kung saan ang isa sa apat na Pauli na operasyon ay inilapat sa
k-th qubit ng |ψ⟩ at malalaman natin mula sa syndrome kung aling Pauli na operasyon ito kaya maitutuwid natin ito kung
kailangan. Sa partikular kung susukat tayo ng syndrome at gagawa ng angkop na pagtutuwid ay makakakuha tayo ng estado ng
anyo na ipinapakita sa screen na kritikal ay isang product state. Mayroon tayong ating orihinal na hindi nasirang encoding bilang ang
kanang-kamay na tensor factor na siyang pinaka-mahalaga dito at sa kaliwa ay mayroon tayong density matrix ρ na
naglalarawan ng random na error syndrome ngunit wala nang kaugnayan sa sistemang pinakamahalaga sa atin na
nasa kanan dahil naituwid na ang mga pagkakamali. Sa puntong ito ay maaari na nating itapon ang mga syndrome qubit o i-reset ang mga ito sa
kaso na gusto nating gamitin muli ang mga ito at iyon ay talagang mahalaga dahil ito ang paraan kung saan ang randomness o entropy
na nabuo ng mga pagkakamali ay inalis mula sa sistema at iyon ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng discretization ng mga Pagkakamali, kahit man lang para sa unitary
na mga pagkakamali. Sa esensya, sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat ng syndrome ay epektibo nating ini-project ang pagkakamali sa isang pagkakamaling inilalarawan ng
isang Pauli Matrix. Sa unang tingin ay mukhang napakaganda upang maging totoo na maitutuwid natin ang mga arbitrary na unitary na pagkakamali
tulad nito, pati na rin ang mga pagkakamaling napaka-maliit at halos hindi kapansin-pansin sa kanilang sarili. Ngunit ang mahalagang maiisip dito
ay ito ay isang unitary na pagkakamali sa isang qubit at ayon sa disenyo ng code ang isang operasyon sa isang qubit ay hindi maaaring baguhin ang
estado ng Logical qubit na ine-encode. Ang lahat ng magagawa nito ay ang ilipat ang estado palabas ng espasyo ng mga wastong
encoding ngunit pagkatapos ang mga pagtutuwid ay dinadala ito pabalik sa kung nasaan ito. Sa huli isaalang-alang natin kung ano ang nangyayari
kapag ang isang arbitrary, hindi kinakailangan unitary, na pagkakamali ay nangyayari. Ang setup ay katulad ng dati
na-encode na natin ang isang qubit sa 9 gamit ang Shore code at may ilang arbitrary na pagkakamaling kinakatawan ng isang qubit channel na
nangyayari sa isa sa mga qubit. Tulad ng makikita natin, lahat ay magiging maganda halos sa katulad na paraan
tulad ng nangyari para sa mga unitary na pagkakamali at ang unang hakbang patungo sa pag-verify nito ay ang isaalang-alang ang Kraus na representasyon ng ating
pagkakamali. Ang maaari nating gawin ngayon ay ang sundin nang eksakto ang katulad na pangangatwiran tulad ng para sa mga unitary na pagkakamali maliban na i-apply natin ang pangangatwiran
sa mga Kraus matrix kaysa sa isang unitary Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang pagkakamali
Sa partikular ang bawat Kraus Matrix ay maaaring ipahayag bilang linear na kombinasyon ng mga Pauli matrix at nagpapahintulot ito sa atin na
ipahayag ang aksyon ng pagkakamaling Φ na ito sa alinmang qubit K na nangyayari sa anyo na ipinapakita dito sa
screen. Ang lahat ng talagang ginagawa natin dito ay ang palawakin ang mga Kraus matrix bilang mga linear na kombinasyon ng mga Pauli
matrix. Kung pagkatapos ay kakalkulahin at susukat natin ang error syndrome at maitatuwid ang anumang pagkakamaling nahayag ay makakakuha tayo ng
katulad na uri ng estado sa nakuha natin sa kaso ng isang unitary na pagkakamali. Hindi ko na dadaan sa mga detalye, halos katulad ito sa unitary
na kaso at medyo mas makalat din upang isulat ngunit sa konseptwal na pagsasalita ay medyo simple
Dapat banggitin ko na ito ay lahat ay nag-ge-generalize sa iba pang quantum error correcting code kasama ang mga code na makakaituwid ng mga pagkakamali sa maraming
qubit. Sa ganitong kaso ang mga pagkakamali sa maraming qubit ay maaaring ipahayag bilang mga linear na kombinasyon ng mga tensor product ng mga Pauli
matrix at naaayon ang iba't ibang posibleng syndrome ay maglalarawan ng mga Pagtutuwid na ginagawa sa maraming qubit kaysa sa isa lamang
na qubit. Ngunit ang pinagbabatayang ideya ay eksaktong katulad. Muli, sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat ng syndrome
ay epektibo nating ini-project o kino-collapse ang mga pagkakamali sa isang discrete na hanay ng mga posibilidad na kinakatawan ng mga tensor
product ng mga Pauli matrix. At sa pamamagitan ng pagwawasto ng mga pagkakamaling iyon ibig sabihin ang mga Pauli na pagkakamali ay mababawi natin ang orihinal
na naka-encode na estado. Samantala, ang anumang randomness na nabuo sa proseso ay inilipat sa mga syndrome qubit na maaari nating
itapon o i-reset na mahalaga dahil iyon ang paraan ng pag-aalis ng entropy na nabuo ng mga pagkakamali at mga sukat ng syndrome mula
sa sistema. At iyon ang katapusan ng aralin kung saan nagkaroon tayo ng unang sulyap sa
quantum na pagtutuwid ng pagkakamali kasama ang 9 qubit Shore code at ang discretization ng mga Pagkakamali. Umaasa akong makasama mo sa
susunod na aralin kung saan tatalakayin natin ang stabilizer formalism na nagbibigay sa atin ng malakas na kasangkapan para sa paglalarawan at
pag-aanalisa ng isang malaki at kawili-wiling klase ng quantum error correcting code kasama ang mga promising na kandidato para sa
tunay na mga quantum computer. Paalam hanggang sa muli.